[Musique]
Daniel green militent depuis longtemps
pour une réforme du mode de scrutin
l'ancien candidat du Parti vert du
Canada pense que le résultat des
élections prouve une fois de plus qu'il
faut changer le système électoral si on
regarde la carte
41% du vote populaire et 90e ça veut
dire qu'ils ont 41% du vote
mais ils ont 73% du pouvoir la CAQ et
les libéraux ont bénéficié du système
actuel la part des sièges qu'ils ont
rapporté et plus importantes que leur
part des suffrages mais c'est l'inverse
pour les trois autres formations
politiques c'est comme si une partie de
leurs électeurs et la totalité dans le
cas des conservateurs avait perdu leur
vote et la poubelle électorale c'est là
où on jette les votes alors le Parti
conservateur poubelle PQ poubelle Québec
solidaire poubelle c'est des votes qui
sont 100% non recyclables alors c'est
non seulement c'est anti-démocratique
c'est aussi très pas très écologique et
quand on sent que notre vote ne compte
pas mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
croire qu'on est représenté
démocratiquement si le Québec avait un
mode de scrutin proportionnel pur comme
en Israël le CAC serait minoritaire avec
une cinquantaine de sièges et les quatre
parties d'opposition en aurait remporté
entre 16 et 19
ça qui s'est passé hier c'est-à-dire la
démonstration que ce système là est
brisé et tordu et comme disait un éveil
démocratiquement effects les citoyens
sans que leur vote compte de moins en
moins François Legault s'était engagé à
réformer le mode de scrutin mais il a
renié sa promesse une fois portée au
pouvoir par le système actuel son
gouvernement avait élaboré le projet de
loi 39 qui visait la mise en place de ce
qu'on appelle un scrutin proportionnel
mixte à compensation régionale avec ce
système les électeurs auraient deux
votes tu votes pour qu'un candidat donc
le mode de soutien actuel puis tu
choisis aussi de partir que tu préfères
géographiquement le Québec serait
redécoupé en 80 circonscriptions
s'ajouterait 45 circonscriptions de
compensation réparties dans 17 régions
ou des députés seraient élus selon le
vote populaire exprimé
avec ce modèle le CAC aurait remporté 75
sièges les libéraux 16 Québec solidaire
14 alors que le Parti Québécois et les
conservateurs en auraient remporté 10 la
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
serait bien différente système mix
professionnel a été créé après la
deuxième guerre mondiale en Allemagne et
ça fonctionne très bien en Allemagne on
a du gouvernement stable efficace des
gens on voit l'Australie la
Nouvelle-Zélande
l'Irlande ont tous réglé ça et nous au
Québec au Canada on est encore dans le
vieux système quand nous partenaires du
commonworth ont changé leur scrutin le
débat est donc relancé mais rien ne
changera si le gouvernement logo
maintient sa position ça prend la
volonté politique ça prend quelqu'un qui
décide que c'est important la démocratie
ça va reprendre quelqu'un qu'il croit
que la démocratie avec un D majuscule et
plus importantes que gagner des sièges
les parties d'opposition ont fait
entendre leur voix reste à voir si les
citoyens emboîteront le pas ici Olivier
Bachard Radio-Canada Montréal